Je veux juste rentrer chez moi et ressentir toutes
les bonnes vibrations de retour au Canada parce
que j'ai obtenu tout votre soutien, tirez
et sauvez le service d'opale d'orichalcos sur la
communauté pour ignorer schlemm non monsieur non
premier Canadien une apostrophe la
certaine manière à vous plus tard fusion  connaître aussi
le gang en trop avec nous lamb
the pie Maria Sharapova German sis a
Leela
Amir champion need si vous ne faites pas de repas
en tant qu'italien le reste maintenant 73 comme une
nouvelle capacité bien dite je ne veux vraiment
pas changer  et je pense que j'ai juste une
très bonne équipe de soutien autour de moi à
la fin de la journée, je suis toujours
humain quoi qu'il arrive et j'ai des parents
et des amis incroyables qui m'ont juste aidé à rester
ancré pour ne pas que Bianca et son
équipage voient le  Veronica est ici la semaine pour
rester non - comme sur le chat ne s'assied pas avec le
sol agneau un entraîneur Sylvia nous savons
ce qu'une robe montre ne vivent pas près de la
secrétaire le mile supplémentaire citron f-150 moi
un nombre heureux d'étages d'un métal
ultra  -grande cour attribuée patron si nous allons
Raja oc  tagon que su cabeza para champion
sur le circuit psycho super hunky
appelé El Prat Sigma sur les
déchets d'avion et les opérations de sauvetage el dólar
agent Amato multi-modalité le long de la
politique Congo LaHood Stanley pour cent mes
pâtes ne nous laissent pas travailler une vengeance PK '
plus  Rue Jean.  Onge LeDoux Canada Maria